[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 6 juillet bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de cette édition le
début ce soir des vacances d'été les
écoliers ne retrouveront leur classe
qu'en septembre et d'ici là c'est une
tradition les cahiers de vacances vont
les accompagner pendant deux mois
certaines références sont d'ailleurs
yvelinoise comme jules et léonie conçu à
chatou à côté des révisions des bases
colère et de la culture générale du
patrimoine de l'écologie et des voyages
est la grande fête du cinéma s'ouvre
aujourd'hui après l'annulation en 2020
le festival de cannes fait son grand
retour c'est jusqu'au 17 juillet ça
tenait encore des films sélectionnés
sont financés en partie par la région
ile-de-france et des yvelinois aussi
seront sur la croisette depuis qu'à nous
retrouverons vincent mirabel professeur
de cinéma de versailles
et puis autre retrouvailles après deux
ans d'absence la 360 8e fête des loges
est installée jusqu'au 15 août en forêt
de saint germain en laye sur place 180
attractions qui attendent les visiteurs
reportage n'est fait une affirmation
également dans ce journal oui c'est
possible dans devenez ces animaux de
compagnie en vacances avec soi un
reportage tout à l'heure auprès de la
spa
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres ce
mardi 6 juillet jour aussi des résultats
du baccalauréat 2021 depuis ce matin les
18000 à 7 164 candidats yvelinois
découvre s'ils ont obtenu le précieux
sésame ou s'ils devront passer au
rattrapage une édition forcément
particulière basée essentiellement sur
le contrôle continu avec les seules
épreuves de philosophie et du grand oral
maintenu prévu initialement en ligne sur
la plateforme cyclades crise sanitaire
oblige certains résultats ont été
affichés dans les établissements mais
pas de scènes de liesse ou de larmes
comme à l'accoutumée on écoute la
réaction d'une des loups et des
lauréates et du baccalauréat 2021
collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude au lycée descartes c'est à
montigny le bretonneux à 10 heures j'ai
regardé sur sur internet sur les
différents sites que ce soit l'académie
de versailles ou sur cyclades et avait
été saturé donc j'ai un peu cherché un
peu partout et un moment j'ai réussi à
trouver mon nom et après j'ai appris
qu'il y avait
et résultat qui était publié au lycée
donc me suis dit qu'on allait jeter un
coup d'oeil
après avec la situation sanitaire façon
je pense qu'il est ils veulent éviter au
maximum des regroupements donc j'y suis
allé avec une aide je pense que le
contrôle continu a quand même aidé
certains parce qu'il fallait travailler
toute l'année
ce mardi c'était également le dernier
jour de classe pour les élèves de
primaire est une tradition pendant les
vacances d'été celle des cahiers de
vacances afin de consolider les acquis
de l'année scolaire et de façon ludique
parmi les références les cahiers de
vacances jules et léonie est lancée par
deux yvelinoise en 2019 elles ont créé
un nouveau numéro cette année le
reportage à ce sujet d'astrid bergère de
nicolas landry et la voix de célia gars
de son goût jules et léonie ses deux
enfants sont les héros des cahiers de
vacances éponyme créée dans les yvelines
en 2019
le but les jeunes consolident leurs
acquis cette année un nouveau cahier de
ce1 vers le ce2 est sorti dans celui ci
les deux personnes pour le tour du monde
ils ont un deltaplane de tapas de
magique qui va leur faire faire le tour
du monde
ils disent au revoir à leurs familles
leurs amis sont là et l'arrivée
l'appareil la famille bien les
accueillir et cette fois ci ils sont
sans le périgord en voile
gorges de la dordogne de façon ludique
avec des jeux et des dessins du monde
entier les enfants en découvre un peu
plus sur la terre l'une des
cofondatrices et professeurs des écoles
et ne trouvait pas de cahier de vacances
a conseillé aux élèves
c'est ainsi qu'est née l'idée j'avais
vraiment dans le dans le coeur et dans
la tête de proposer à mes élèves des
cahiers de vacances en fait qu'ils
fassent grandir l'enfant dans toutes ses
dimensions qui est un bon niveau
scolaire qui est une exigence au niveau
des exercices et du contenu
et puis également que l'enfant apprenne
énormément de choses au niveau de la
culture générale au niveau du patrimoine
l'amour de son pays l'environnement le
monde qui l'entourent en fait voilà qui
soit vraiment mûri les deux fondatrices
ont aussi souhaité évoquer l'état de la
planète
il voit aussi des océans qui sont plein
de déchets plein de plastique est
vraiment salée préoccupent-ils 10 mai
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette
magnifique terre en plus ils ont la
chance contrairement à nous de pouvoir
du ciel avec leur deltaplane donc c'est
vrai qu'ils sont là ils sont bien
sensibilisés et et voilà il découvre
vraiment là le bonheur que leur donne en
fait une vie simple 3000 exemplaires ont
été vendus la première année 6000 la
deuxième pour 2021 les deux
entrepreneuses espère en vendre autant
que l'année dernière mais pour elle
le but reste la qualité des cahiers de
vacances comme chaque semaine le point
sur la vaccination dans les yvelines la
préfecture a annoncé ce mardi que quatre
centres resterait ouvert cet été à saint
germain en laye mantes-la-jolie au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et au centre
commercial vélizy 2 au 4 juillet 666
1494 personnes avaient reçu une première
injection dans le département près de 19
mille cinq cents de plus en une semaine
le nombre de personnes totalement
vacciner progresse également 470 69 1250
plus 50 milles depuis le 28 juin au 4
centres de vaccination vers cet été vont
venir s'ajouter également l'annoncé la
préfecture des opérations de vaccination
éphémère sur les aires d'autoroutes est
de morainvilliers au coeur des quartiers
des mureaux dans la base de loisirs de
verneuil sur seine ou encore dans la
fanzone de trappes
[Musique]
et des strass des paillettes mais
surtout du rêve à présent dans ce
journal la 74e édition du festival de
cannes débute aujourd'hui et durant une
dizaine de jours les projections vont se
multiplier les stars du septième art
défileront sur le célèbre tapis rouge et
la région ile-de-france va également
participer à cette quinzaine avec et des
financements de films qui sont au
programme et pour parler de ce sujet il
n'est pas sur la croisette justement
c'est michael et demi d'euro bonds soir
en soir strass et paillettes j'arrive
tout de suite les gorilles vous êtes un
habitué alors il ya des films soutenus
par la région ile de france cette année
à cannes alors oui grégory 20 films
présents cette année au festival de
cannes ont reçu le soutien de la région
parmi eux on retrouve quatre films en
compétition france de bruno dumont
soutenu à hauteur de 334 milles euros
par la région tout s'est bien passé de
françois ozon soutenu à hauteur de 320
milles euros
aéro d'asghar farhadi qui a soutenu à
hauteur de 95 1200 euros et enfin titane
de julia ducournau soutenu au titre du
fonds de soutien auteurs de trois cent
trente mille euros
on regarde justement un extrait de ce
film
[Musique]
nommé obama
prêcher la haine
est-ce que ça s'arrête
[Musique]
moi je
alors au total la région ile-de-france
alloué un budget de 22 millions d'euros
au cinéma c'est la première collectivité
territoriale française pour le soutien
au cinéma et à l'audiovisuel les aides
peuvent aujourd'hui aller jusqu'à à
600000 euros pour les films de cinéma on
écoute la vice présidente chargée de la
culture à la région florence portelli il
y a vraiment un grand cinéma français
c'est important pour nous de soutenir
cette création qui fait la fierté de
notre pays la culture permet aussi à
notre pays de rayonner
mais c'est extrêmement important et puis
ce sont des emplois c'est énormément
d'emplois
c'est de la création et puis c'est du
rêve ça fait du bien de rêver
aujourd'hui et le film nous permet ça
alors ce budget permet de soutenir cent
cinquante mille emplois sur la région
les coudes florence portelli aux
finances par exemple tout ce qui est
avant la réalisation tout ce qui est
post production donc c'est vraiment très
globale et puis on a ces derniers temps
renforcer nos z au cinéma même à travers
des coproductions internationales où il
y avait une part minoritaire des
français donc on essaye en plus de
renforcer l'attractivité de la région
ile-de-france en attirant de plus en
plus de réalisations au sein de notre
belle région
22 millions d'euros sont donc alloué
cinéma chaque année la région ne veut
pas s'arrêter là elle veut continuer à
aider cette filière l'une des idées
consiste à soutenir les scénaristes il
ya notamment eu ces dernières années une
augmentation des bourses et une école
des scénaristes est en projet grégory si
michael pour toutes ces précisions on
aura l'occasion de reparler de ce sujet
dans l'une de nos éditions de la semaine
prochaine et on poursuit à cette
discussion sur le festival de cannes
avec mon invité alors il n'est pas en
visioconférence il ya quelques problèmes
de connexion directement à quelques
puisqu'il est à cannes en ce moment il
est par téléphone c'est vincent mirabel
bonsoir oui vous êtes professeur de
cinéma basé à versailles et vous êtes
l'auteur entre autres de l'histoire du
cinéma pour les nuls c'est aux éditions
first alors je le disais coup d'envoi
officiel aujourd'hui de la 74e édition
du festival de cannes
c'est même à 19h25 très précisément que
va être lancé cette soixante quatorzième
édition avec la cérémonie d'ouverture en
maîtresse de cérémonie doria tillier
le président du jury forcément aussi à
spike lee et c'est un festival vincent
mirabel un peu particulier un an après
son annulation
avec crise sanitaire oblige il se
déroule en juillet est ce qu'un festival
qui se déroule en juillet à votre avis
ça change énormément la donne ou
finalement ça change pas beaucoup les
choses cette année
alors ça change la donne si vous êtes
amateurs de football ce soir il ya une
concurrence entre le film d'ouverture
qui et annette de leos carax et une
demi-finale d'euros alors qu'ils étaient
mêlés syriaque seulement voilà entre
l'italie et l'espagne pour ce qui
évidemment m
et le cinéma et de football c'est un
terrible dilemme
mais pour l'enfance le defistival y est
généralement ça ne change pas grand
chose parce que le soleil est encore
rendez-vous comme au mois de mai il fait
simplement un peu plus chaud mais les
coeurs fonds heureux de se retrouver
justement après une édition 2009 1 et
qui a été annulé à cause justement du
coc u19 qui était primordial que le
festival puisse faire son retour cette
année c'est en quelque sorte la fête
pour peut-être la relance du cinéma
puisque les cinémas eux-mêmes ont été
fermés pendant plusieurs mois oui c'est
primordial de se retrouver vous savez il
ya un abîme qui dit loin des yeux loin
du coeur
ça faisait deux ans que les gens de
cannes et les festivals du monde entier
n'a pas pu de se retrouver dans cette
belle ville qui est l'organisatrice du
plus grand festival du monde
et bien il y as malgré la jauge un peu
réduite énormément de nouveau cette
année et il ya la joie de se retrouver
de communes est de nouveau à l'intérieur
des femmes et on va parler de votre
programme sur place dans un instant ce
que vous animez des conférences déjà un
premier avis sur cette sélection
officielle vous parliez de ce film
manette qui est en ouverture avec adam
driver marion cotillard film de léo
carax des cinéastes de renom aussi qui
sont dans cette sélection officielle on
pense à nanni moretti à jacques audiard
également au thaïlandais apichatpong
weerasethakul qui signe son premier film
en anglais memoria présence forte aussi
de la musique on va finir aussi ce
festival de cannes avec du sourire du
rire avec le film de clôture qui est un
oss 117 cette année est ce qu'il ya un
film qui vous attire
parmi cette sélection pléthorique cette
année alors moi je suis attiré par le
film de paul verhoeven qui est déjà un
petit bruit ce teint d'une aura foule
furieuse parce que beaucoup de gens
parlent aujourd'hui mais évidemment
c'est annette que j'aurai le plaisir à
voir en premier en l'occurrence dès
demain matin car les places ce soir
était absolument rempli d'emblée et donc
dès demain matin à pied d'oeuvre
8h30 je suis dans une grande salle de
2800 personnes pour assister ce film
annette dont je me réjouis de découvrir
la nouvelle oeuvre de leos carax
or concernant le jury on connaissait le
président depuis un an bien sûr spike
lee
mais non de ses acolytes a été dévoilé
il ya peu on cite bien sûr mylène farmer
est l'acteur sud coréen song kang ho
qu'on avait vu notamment dans parasites
qui était votre coup de coeur sur l
édition 2010 9 du festival de cannes qui
a eu en plus la palme d'or il ya
également la réalisatrice franco
sénégalaise mati diop les acteurs
français tahar rahim mélanie laurent
l'actrice américaine maggie et ghislaine
paul clébert mendoça filho gesicka
jessica hausner
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
casting cinq étoiles pour ce retour du
festival d'automne ait un bon casting
birac bigarrée comme à l'accoutumée fait
que dire qu'il ya une volonté de
mélanger différents métiers différentes
sensibilités différentes nationalités et
moi je me réjouis de cet équilibre qui
permet je dirais de d'échangés de
s'enrichir les uns les autres
donc je trouve que c'est un palmarès en
tout cas au pas de repas renom papale
m'arrêter un jury qui ne prêtent pas je
dirais aux commentaires excessifs donc
déjà gros travail de la part de l'équipe
organisatrice
alors vous êtes accueil vincent me
rebelle depuis hier soir quel va être
votre programme dans les prochains jours
bah écoutez en arrivant à cannes j'avais
quitté paris sous la pluie hier je suis
arrivé avec un seul est un flan j'ai dû
immédiatement enfilé mes lunettes de
soleil là je suis heureux de rendre
jaloux tout un tas de gens tellement je
me sens gâtés et mon programme demain
matin s'est enchaîné avec un premier
film donc à 8h30 et ensuite quatre
autres films dans la journée je finis à
00h40
voilà c'est assez chargé
mais c'était tellement un bonheur de
découvrir des oeuvres bien différente
des documentaires des fictions et puis
on voyage dans le monde entier
l'accès est actuellement je dirais
correct en ce sens qu'on peut accéder à
des billets à condition d'être un peu
patient
mais en tout cas c'est ouvert il y a
vingt mille spectateurs néanmoins mais
c'est deux fois moins que d'habitude
donc il ya des clashs avec aussi des
conférences que vous animez une dernière
question ce qu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien
est ce que ce festival vous fait encore
rêver aujourd'hui soixante quatorzième
édition vous n'en avez pas sur moi votre
premier festival est ce que ça vous fait
toujours rêver
le festival de cannes le fils qui
veulent me fait toujours rêver vous
savez le coeur et les vibrations du
coeur grapho fait mention que génèrent
les réalisateurs sont vraiment porteur
de sens et je trouve que le film a
aujourd'hui est un vecteur différence
parce qu'ils nous ouvrent et il nous
fait vibrer nous sentir humain est dense
et entendez me fait très important de se
sentir humain et je dirais heureux
capable de vibrer merci au cinéma et on
a vu bien sûr l'affiché de ce 64e
festival de cannes qui est un petit peu
coupé par le bandeau un bien sûr avec le
visage de spike lee qui est le président
du jury de cette année merci vincent
mirabel d'avoir été avec nous merci
grégory et je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de cinéma basé à versailles
et auteur entre autres de l'histoire du
cinéma pour les nuls c'est aux éditions
first
[Musique]
dans la page culture également la pièce
de théâtre participatif j'habite
hashtags saint quentin en yvelines en
représentation d'abord au théâtre
national le mercredi 7 juillet à 20h30
puis le vendredi 9 juillet 7 à 20h30 au
scarabée à la verrière bixente ma sortie
stéphane et nicolas dont brice sont
allés aux dernières répétitions regardez
c'est la question à laquelle la pièce de
théâtre j'habite sky apporte des
réponses une mise en scène avec cinq
habitants saint quentinois de comédiens
accompagne ses acteurs en herbe
il porte la parole de la population des
douze communes de l'agglomération
jerry kelly pr je n'avais alors moi je
vais parler de mon appartement où j'ai
habité en premier à elancourt et qui
était vraiment un bâtiment peu ordinaire
on va dire où il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes donc voilà faut venir au
spectacle pour le voir peut être
l'entendre ce qui est aussi important
c'est de porc donc de porter la parole
des habitants des personnes qui ont bien
voulu témoigner pour pouvoir donc
présenté un peu leur vie leur vécu au
niveau de la vie nouvelle
guyancourt toi ville prévient mme annie
quoi ou encore qu les siens ce spectacle
est une succession de scènes lecture de
témoignages des mouvements sur scène et
projections un projet construit en
partenariat avec le musée de la ville
mise en scène par catherine laine de la
compagnie 7 septembre j'ai recueilli des
témoignages au j'étais presque à 150
témoignages sur les douze communes j'ai
fait un gros travail dans les
associations
je suis allé à la rencontre des gens et
cetera et cetera
et ce spectacle donc parle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des douze
communes et du lien qu'on peut créer
entre elles mais surtout de l'humain
surtout des habitants de ce qu'ils y
font ce qu'ils y rêve ce qu'il projette
dans leur vie la première représentation
le mercredi 7 juillet au théâtre
national avant une seconde prévue le
vendredi 9 juillet au scarabée de la
verrière pour découvrir les multiples
visages de saint quentin en yvelines le
coup tous d'accord c'était la maison
qu'il nous fallait
al'approche des vacances d'été la spa
renouvelle sa campagne de prévention
pour limiter les abandons avoir un
animal de compagnie c'est aussi trouver
une solution pour l'emmener ou bien le
faire garder pendant les vacances
une contrainte qui peut paraître
complexe mais qui se déroule bien avec
un minimum d'organisation témoignage
d'une adoptantes à orgeval avec eléonore
sinoquet loulou autrefois mont blanc à
13 ans cet été il partira en vacances
avec sa nouvelle famille qui l'a adopté
à la spa d'orgeval en avril dernier en
plein troisième confinement une adoption
qu'on appelle sos loulou est âgé et à
quelques soucis de santé pour autant il
était inenvisageable pour ses
propriétaires de se séparer de lui
pendant leurs congés
mon mari charge là
voiture tout se prépare et on amène la
veille la caisse pour qu'il s'habitue
quand c'est le moment de partir c'est le
dernier avec moi à rentrer alors moi et
lui nous sommes à l'arrière ça fait
sourire nos amis mais c'est pas grave
comme ça il est moins frustré parce
qu'il ya des chats qui aime qui aiment
pas et on n'aime pas le drogué donc
comme ça je suis à côté et avec cette
nouvelle caisse
il est attaché il à son collier et il
est attaché dans la caisse la caisse est
attaché au siège et il peut naviguer
dans le coffre
toutes ces affaires en plus des valises
du couple sans oublier la litière et la
laisse car lorsque le couple arrive sur
son lieu de vacances quelques heures
voire une journée sont nécessaires pour
que le loup s'habituer à son nouvel
environnement
pour les sorties en extérieur c'est en
laisse d'abord à chaque fois quand on
arrive par contre on regarde les
endroits qui peuvent être dangereux pour
lui et là où il faut préserver parce que
après nous on les laisse libres et on
surveille on préconise les endroits où
on voit que ça pourrait être dangereux
il pourrait passer
donc on protège tout comme catherine la
spa appelle à ne pas laisser ces animaux
cet été allez viens mon chrysostome et
n'ont pas de voiture mais quel but roman
tu peux me faire ça non
pourquoi me sortir du refuge pour faire
ça un an après
cette lumière c'est la même que la
dernière fois allez pour les baraques
chaque année en france ce sont cent
mille chats et chiens qui sont
abandonnés avec un pic pendant la
période estivale
malgré les solutions évoquées vous y
ferez vos vacances trop bien comment ces
paradis vous dire que j'avais peur de
départs en vacances
[Musique]
c'est une tradition à
saint-germain-en-laye la fée des loges
revient pour une 360 huitième édition
après une année et 2020 marqué par la
crise sanitaire et par une annulation
justement en raison du kobe 19 les 180
attractions sont installés est prête à
accueillir tout l'été des milliers de
visiteurs bixente maria ressenti tebbane
comme un air d'inauguration pour les 180
attractions de la fête des loges après
deux ans d'absence un rendez vous qui a
l'instinct d'un câble pour de nombreux
visiteurs sa marque l'été en fête le
début de la fête des loges et du coup
l'année dernière comme s'est pas ouvert
l'impression de pavant d'été en fait
c'est eux qui nous marque le début des
vacances en pénalités compris un défilé
festif a été organisée pour célébrer
cette réouverture des réjouissances
marque du soulagement des organisateurs
après une édition 2009 un anonyme
envoyée par le bout du tunnel exactement
donc c'est vrai que là debout
d'avoir eu assez de sortie de crise en
tout cas et pouvoir redémarrer en plus
par la fête des loges qui est une des
foires les plus familial que je
connaisse en juin deux cas c'était super
beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de plaisir
on a vécu quand même voilà seize mois 18
mois compliqués l'année dernière ça
avait été terrible que de prendre la
décision je crois qu'aucun maire avant
n'avait eu à prendre cette décision que
d'annuler la fête des loges pendant les
prochaines semaines jeunes les familles
pourront trouver leur bonheur au milieu
des autos tamponneuses de la pêche aux
canards ou encore des nombreux manèges à
sensations fortes
nous on revient plutôt pour les petits
lots on a on a des enfants dont un quart
en bas âge donc on fait on fait plutôt
plutôt calme et bon ça c'est agréable
aussi y'a pleins pleins de jeux sympas
une fête qui aura attendu après le 30
juin et la levée des restrictions du
nombre de visiteurs pour ouvrir mais ces
retrouvailles avec le public se
prolongeront en musique tous les soirs
sans exception jusqu'au 15 août prochain
pour refermer ce journal un mot de ce
sport et du football une information
mercato c'était pressenti depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est désormais
officiel matteo guendouzi originaire de
poissy rejoint l'olympique de marseille
l'opération après avec une option
d'achat estimée à 11 millions d'euros
le jeune international français de 22
ans formé au paris saint germain a passé
sa visite médicale aujourd'hui il
connaîtra son quatrième club chez les
professionnels après lorient à arsenal
et le hertha berlin elle yvelinois
devrait être titulaire à l'om la saison
prochaine
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant ne
manquez pas un humour un numéro spécial
de notre magazine 7,8 culture consacré à
france miniature à l'occasion des 30 ans
du parc installé à elancourt belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]